there first of all um you need actually
researchers who who really care about uh
the the kind of the real world and
aren't satisfied just by kind of
experiments on synthetic data and things
like that you like you need to be able
to talk the language of value as in
value for the customer with your
researchers right or at least with some
of them sure um so that was that was one
thing I learned I learned a lot about
the import of um
assumptions um in terms of the
assumptions that I make for my
experimentations are they going to um
are they going to still apply in the
real world are they good
assumptions um and I learned a lot about
the importance of uh evaluating um
models and algorithms on on real world
scenarios and on real world data uh
which by the way is a massive challenge
When You're Building things that need to
optimize versus an external system which
you you can't control um um and that was
another thing specifically at kenu that
that if you can't simulate the real
world then kind of you know either try
to simulate specific aspects of it that
you can simulate sure right but don't
build something which then you know uh
you're going to rely upon
and um and then and then actually it's
it's a you know you can't
[Music]
essentially yes cette welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me um
it's it's a pleasure having you here and
I'm really excited to talk about your
journey and about you know not just the
entrepreneurial Journey but the personal
one ER and talking about everything from
what you're doing today to to H stuff
that works and and the different things
that you've gotten to take a part of
over the years it sounds like a really
interesting Journey with a lot of
different experiences touching on really
high impact areas from from Health Care
to accessibility so I'm excited to dive
in and to unravel a little a little bit
together so thank you for being here
thank you thank you looking forward to
talking so so take me back how did you
find yourself even in the tech space
originally so um I grew up in the UK and
I moved to Israel uh when I was 26 years
old uh just got married uh finished opan
relatively quickly and I had come with
this kind of uh dream of getting into
kind of business Consulting and and
things like that like had a degree in
physics I had spent three years working
for the Jewish community and um I wanted
someone to kind of come along and train
me and what I realized pretty quickly
was that that Israel wasn't really set
up for that as in there are a few kind
of Consulting companies and places where
they have kind of entry-level training
programs but most of it wasn't that so I
started thinking about what my skills
were I knew that I would had strong
analytical skills and so I started to
look for roles in kind of the uh the
data analysis uh space um obviously uh
connections are everything here and and
few uh uh through a few friends that I
made through the amas CL and things like
that eventually I found my way to a
company called super derivatives who it
was 2008 and they had a platform for
real-time pricing of financial
derivatives so uh options and things
like that their platform was based on
Market data that had to come uh from
Brokers and exchanges and things like
that and there were a lot of quality
problems with the data that was coming
in so they needed to come in they
specifically brought me in for their
interest rates product uh someone who
could start to build processes for
actually understanding the quality of
data that was coming coming into the
platform so um that was really
interesting it was a very interesting
time to join that kind of company
because when was this this was in 2008
so I joined them in August 2008 wow just
before the uh right before December
right before the
crisis um I survived a couple of rounds
of uh of cutbacks there and I also got
to witness how the focus of the company
changed so real-time derivative pricing
become
less of a thing when the market is kind
of shutting down and no one's making any
deals but
suddenly it because it's all about
short-term trading not just that it's
also just in general the volume of
Trades went down during the crisis but
suddenly everyone needed to go back and
reevaluate portfolios uh throughout the
crisis and they had just kind of put put
out a re-evaluation uh product and
suddenly that got all of the focus and
there were a lot of new deals that were
based around that um so it was an
interesting it was an interesting place
to learn um I guess after a while I I
found myself not so connected to the um
the financial derivative
space um and through another friend I I
basically found my way into a company
called kenu that um that had would had
built a product for um management and
optimization of digital marketing
campaigns at the time specifically
search engine marketing um and they had
a budding uh social product and
basically I joined there as an
analyst um they needed someone who could
come in and kind of connect with their
work they were doing in research with
their kind of with the real world and
their customers um they had just gone
from like a very simple rule-based
algorithm to this model based we called
it model based then what I guess we now
call machine learning but it it was very
simple linear aggressions and things
like that but still modelbased uh
bidding algorithm and it worked in the
lab and it didn't really work so well in
their field and no one could really
explain why um and even for the small
number of customers who were using it at
the time no one could really also like
have the conversation with them about
what was going wrong and and what was
the what was the hurle there well I
think that the research team um it
varied but I guess the driving force in
the research team was kind of very um
orientated towards statistics and and
and research and with less thought
necessarily about well the assumptions
that I'm making here right so for
instance I I'll give you an example in
order to Model A and at the time it was
bidding on keywords in order to model
the performance of a keyword right as in
if someone clicks on an ad that was
triggered by this keyword you know
what's the probability that they're
actually going to go and buy something
sure you need a fairly significant
amount of data if you're just basing it
on that uh keyword alone and the
assumptions that were made for the
models just didn't exist in the real
world for the vast majority of keywords
so it was it was that kind of thing I
guess those were the kinds of insights
that I brought in first on the level of
figuring out who is this going to work
for and then kind of why is this not
working for for a whole bunch of people
and through that we grad ually started
to kind of rebuild the algorithm uh we
introduced things like for the first
time you know like not just learning
about keyboard performance from one
keyword but kind of taking a more
machine learning approach and looking
across a whole portfolio and things like
that and I grew in that organization I
went from kind of being an analyst to
being more of I guess an algorithm
developer to a team lead and it was with
them that I then made the trip out to
California for 3 years they needed that
that function of a someone who who
speaks the language of data I guess it
was starting to become then a data
scientist sure uh who can also talk to
uh customers kind of in their own
language um and make Concepts that are
difficult to understand easier to
understand they really felt they needed
that in the field and they wanted to
build a team so I I moved to San
Francisco uh for a few years to kind of
build up that team what what did you
learn about this intersection of data
data analysis and and the real world
scenarios because it sounds like you're
from both of these experiences with
super derivative and also with canu it's
a lot about how do you take data but
then make sense of it in the real
world yeah well so I think what I
learned was that first of all um you
need actually researchers who who really
care about uh the the kind of the real
world and aren't satisfied just by kind
of experiments on synthetic data and
things like that you like you need to be
able to talk the language of value as in
value for the customer with your
researchers right or at least with some
of them sure um so that was that was one
thing I learned I learned a lot about
the importance of um
assumptions um in terms of the
assumptions that I make from my
experimentations are they going to um
are they going to still apply in the
real world are they good
assumptions um and I learned a lot about
the importance of uh evaluating um
models and algorithms on on real world
scenarios and Onre World data uh which
by the way is a massive challenge when
you're building things that need to
optimize versus an external system which
you you can't control um um and that was
another thing specifically at kenu that
that if you can't simulate the real
world then kind of you know either try
to simulate specific aspects of it that
you can simulate sure right but don't
build something which then you know uh
you're going to rely upon and um and
then and then actually it's it's a you
know can't essentially makes a lot of
sense so so what's next up on the
journey so uh couple of years into my
time in uh in California um we uh the
leader of the research team in kenu uh
left and um um by that point I had a
very good relationship with the CTO and
I had a quite a Clear Vision for what I
thought research and kenu needed to do
and so uh we had a conversation he asked
me to come back and manage the team it
was a little bit of a
from a personal perspective the timing
uh the timing of my moves in general has
not been great as my wife will
definitely tell you uh we moved to
California with a 4-month old baby and
we came back with a six-month old baby
wow okay um but um but yeah so uh he
asked me to come back and lead the team
um uh when I came back the the kind of
the key challenge the the there were a
few key challenges that I need to solve
one was a a product strategy challenge
which was the until that point we had
been entirely you know our Flagship uh
products from the research team were
very much about um bid optimization what
had happened was that the Publishers
like Google and Facebook they were
starting to take care of bid
optimization and they had more data and
more uh capabilities they can do
realtime uh bidding and so it started to
reach the point where our algorithms
could kind of no longer compete with
them and there was this story well you
don't want to give your data to Google
you know and all of that sort of stuff
and sure probably quite a good story but
it's still not strong enough for for
businesses not to want those
optimization
capabilities since then due to some of
the uh anti- tracking stuff that Apple
has has done the situation has become
more complicated again but at the time
we needed to kind of make a a bold
decision of well actually we're going to
start leaving some of that to the
Publishers and come in on a higher level
right so we need a portfolio
optimization that can run on top of
Google's bid optimization we need we
need to start to build measurement tools
that can help you understand the
incrementality of one channel versus
another so there was kind of a an
attempt to kind of repurpose the team
towards uh those kind of directions and
then the other thing was that we were
still very much in the place
that as a research group the amount of
research capability that we had didn't
align with the amount of engineering
resources that were available both to
enable the research and then productize
the research um and on the other
hand um there were so many things that
research had done that no one else
really got that there was also a big
burden of support on Research as well um
and so uh during my my last couple of
years there I I kind of led a process
where we actually gradually moved
towards more of a kind of Guild
structure within the research team first
of all so we had engineers and data
scientists within the research team and
instead of having an engineering team
and a data science team and researched
then we we integrated them and and and
had Guild leads and then eventually we
uh we actually integrated the data
scientists into the R&D organization um
and maintained the kind of data science
Guild but um moved all of kind of
support and um moved all of support into
the white art R&D organization as well
as um in making it so that the research
road map was part of the product road
map and so we were more aligned on
engineering resources and things like
that wow okay so quite a journey yeah I
mean it was I I like um I owe a lot of
my professional skills and experience to
my time in in kenu and being given the
opportunity to kind of be tested against
all of these all of these different
kinds of challenges absolutely H how did
you end up in in stuff that works so a a
a guy who had been uh at kenu uh uh
several years previous he had been a a
really strong kind of architect software
engineer at kenu he kind of reached out
to me and he said hey I'm starting to uh
work on this uh uh startup in the um in
their medical space and you know I don't
know about you but for me it was it was
it was good to to be able to start doing
something good rather than just
something in the marketing space and
working with this uh um their their CEO
uh founder who was ya Elish who uh who
had come from uh who had come from ways
and knew an incredible amount about
about crowdsourcing and so sure um you
know it was kind of an opportunity so I
met him and then um and then I met yel
and I was really excited by what they
were doing and she gave me some insight
into the some of the kind of data that
um they already had and I was like yeah
I also at the time was feeling an itch
to be a bit more Hands-On again um and
at the time you know kenu was the
earliest startup I had joined and it was
already 80 people and I wanted to see
what it was like to kind of build
something from the ground up sure uh so
yeah so so so talking me a littleit
about what what that Vision was and and
what and what and the four you spent
four years uh building it out
what was the original vision and how did
it play out as a story so um I think the
vision was
um I guess we could start with the
problem sure the the problem is that um
um so many people deal with chronic
medical conditions um and all of these
medical conditions they just have to be
managed right and whether or not it's
going to be managed well for you depends
on a whole bunch of different things
primarily the quality of your carer
right whether you've got access to kind
of an expert in the field or or or
someone else and then also how well your
specific you know presentation of a
given condition fits with kind of that
condition that condition in general
right because you know no you know it's
not like one size fits all here right
and you know I I know this personally I
don't mind talking about it I have I
have a son with ADHD um and and and my
daughter my oldest daughter also has
ADHD and they have completely different
ADHD she is she is inattentive right um
and and he is is more hyperactive and
impulsive right and the the treatments
that are required for those two
different types of you know ADHD are
very very different and the
the so the stuff that works for each of
them is different yes the stuff that
works is different um and so the idea
was well if we can actually crowdsource
data um from people who are actually
taking the treatments and have had a
wide range of experiences and then
correlate that with some of the other
stuff that they're telling us then maybe
we can actually find uh treatments that
work better especially for specific
individuals or or sub so sounds like a
very practical Hands-On approach let's
get people out that are under the court
that have these issues or that are using
different treatments share I just
recently learned about a somebody that
has a a Parkinson's and their family
members who who are assisting them are
talking about how there's these forums
these communities of people who have
Parkinson's where they share these
treatments and a lot of the times these
are treatments that are not necessarily
ones that are coming from the doctor
these are coming from Real World real
patients real people that are that need
that are actually testing them out yeah
and that was another huge part of the
thesis that people are already doing
this they're already sharing their
experiences they're already on forums
they're already asking questions but no
one is doing anything to structure that
uh data and kind of learn anything from
it sure um so we started with a
survey um actually yel started with a
survey that she built on Google forms
and and and sent to a specific Community
a specific condition and that was the
initial data that I researched and from
that we came to the conclusion okay well
now we need to actually build a product
with a
survey um so um and and you know it was
a a team we had a a a physician on the
team uh we had someone who was kind of
more of an expertise in kind of data Ops
and and and and things like that um we
had a strong couple of strong front
Enders and we kind of we went we uh
built this survey um it was very and I
mean I think this is y's Brilliance uh
there um the thing that she's really
good at is kind of getting people to
share um so both in terms of how we
built the survey the fact that it was
the survey was very informal a lot of
free text rather than you having to
complex things where you have to search
for a specific symptom and then select
it and then move it into a list and all
of that sort of stuff it was just write
down your symptoms will'll deal with the
problem of like normalizing them
afterwards sure um and also she from the
very beginning we had this kind of uh
you know this this idea that you want to
build your own community so that you can
get more more data and more learnings
from it so referral was a big thing
bringing other people onto the platform
getting them to kind of fill in the
survey all of that sort of stuff um
these were all um uh you know big parts
of the system and and data started to
come in
um we uh and and very quickly it got to
the point where I was kind of building a
set of insights off of the data first of
all descriptive statistics and things
like that we started normalizing all of
that free text Data symptoms treatments
and within a few months I was kind of
building the first I would say
descriptive model of uh of kind of
treatment Effectiveness not personalized
at all just kind of based on what we've
told us what might be the effectiveness
range of a given treatment also
considering the fact that about some
treatments we maybe had 10 people who
had tried them and others hundreds and
we didn't just want to assume that the
ones that we had the most data about
were the best but on the other hand we
did have to build in uncertainty for for
the ones that we didn't have and other
kind of potential biases mhm and so what
what so so what happened in the journey
so you know startup everyone wears
multiple caps I was also very uh very
involved in user acquisition that was
partly because I had just come from a
digital marketing company um so one of
the things that we did very successfully
in the beginning was um was Facebook ads
um and getting people to sign up uh
Facebook ads we had like in the
beginning very low cost of user
acquisition and all of that sort of
stuff very quickly we were getting to
tens of thousands and then hundreds of
thousands of people who had kind of uh
filled in the filled in the survey and
that enabled me as well to kind of grow
a team start looking at um both
there were kind of two things that
primarily the research focused on there
so one was processing all of this text
Data um llms weren't really there yet
but Transformers were um and so doing
things like named entity recognition and
stuff like that kind of incorporating
that into the platform so we didn't have
to human normalize everything and then
the other was very much you know um
building out models for kind of specific
insights that we were looking to get
from the data where whe whether it's the
whole question of treatment
Effectiveness or detrimental treatments
or uh you know what is the
diagnostic um um significance of a given
symptom right so so think about how
there are some symptoms that are very
common in lots of different chronic
medical conditions like fatigue right or
joint pain right what are the symptoms
though that are very indicative of a
kind of given a condition and then from
there also to start building out a kind
of diagnostic model or misdiagnosis
model um that was really cool uh using
Transformers to kind of directly process
the text Data combine it with some of
the categorical and numeric data that we
had like people's ages and gender and
all of that sort of stuff and then and
then um you know being able to classify
basically each survey to what uh
condition it beong it belonged to um as
part of that we built this visual
representation this map of chronic
medical conditions which is still kind
of there on the homepage of uh of stuff
that works where we basically took the
the the hidden layer of that model and
and uh which was an embedding and and
did dimensionality reduction to kind of
turn that into a map that was we learned
some interesting interesting things for
that about which conditions were
actually similar to one another and and
all of that kind of thing uh were there
any major things that surprised you in
your findings as you were looking into
the space well first of all I guess um
it surprised me the number of different
things that people will try for a uh for
a given condition both individually like
some people will come and they will say
they've tried 20 different things but
also across the number of people who are
who are you know who are in that
Community I learned some stuff about you
know eventually we got into the whole
area of uh causal uh modeling but even
before we got to that point we started
to think about the kind of potential
biases and the data sure right so for
instance cannabis right was ranked
really highly across a lot in treatments
across a lot of different different
conditions right so on the one hand you
know I don't want be a skeptic and say
that's all that's all bias like the
medical community probably hasn't done
enough in understanding what you know
other the potential actual real benefits
of cannabis but on the other hand you
got to think if someone took cannabis
then there's an ideological component
there right like most people who take
cannabis are predis for their condition
are predisposed to taking cannabis and
therefore kind of more likely to uh to
kind of rank that as effective so it's
kind of like how do you how do you
isolate those kind of uh uh you know
pieces of noise in the the data and
things like that so I if that was a it
it was something that I knew kind of
theoretically but kind of actually
seeing it in the in the data and
understanding that we did have this kind
of this thing that almost the more kind
of the more esoteric the treatment the
more likely it would be that the people
who who who found it right and decided
rather than someone telling them to take
it they they they kind of came to that
conclusion themselves the more likely
they were to then become evangelists for
that sort of thing and and and rate it
really highly so that was kind of it was
an interesting and it was an interesting
challenge at the end of the day um for
the whole proposal of of of kind of uh
you know identifying uh treatment data
another thing that I found really
interesting was that um actually people
weren't necessarily in it for the data
um you would think that you know with
face Facebook and all of these other
social platforms people had enough
spaces to come and talk about their
condition but actually one of the one of
the things that was most you know in
terms of uh user um engagement effective
was the discussion you know we built a
discussion forum and a uh and a a a
place to ask research questions and all
of that sort of stuff and those things
were were actually really really popular
so it surprised me as well how much
people were willing to put into this
without necessarily getting out the end
game of here you're going to find a you
know a treatment that that works for you
um how did you get to
accessibility so so
um at some point uh you know I could
kind of see that I had reached the limit
of what I could do I guess um in stuff
that works and market conditions other
things made me start thinking about okay
maybe I want to move on um and on the
day I kind of decided that I wanted to
move on I sat down and I thought to
myself all right this time I'm not just
going to like I'm not going to keep
doing this thing where someone reaches
out to me with an interesting
opportunity and I end up taking that
opportunity I'm going to create a short
list of things that I actually want from
my next role and let's see if I can you
know to what extent I can get them so I
so I wanted to be in a company that was
doing good I wanted to have you know
really trust the founders I wanted to be
at their management table and I wanted
to join a company where there was
already a research team because I'd
always been it was kind of the opposite
of my previous where I wanted to be more
Hands-On now I wanted to see what I
could do as a manager without the
constant uh impulse uh to be to be
Hands-On and so um that day a friend of
my brothers reached out to me with this
role uh um evinced um and I L you know I
looked at the role and I met uh G first
of all uh the uh co-founder in the GM
Israel um and you know he explained to
me what they were doing and what the
setup was and it just it sounded really
really
interesting um and so we actually went
through a very very quick uh kind of uh
process like within a week I think I met
G and then I met um Asia who was a data
science team lead and um and uh Ben who
uh was the CT who's the
CTO
um there was a i I think a good
chemistry and uh kind of a good match
for the things that I had done with what
what they were looking for at the end of
the day they wanted someone to kind of
really organize and lead the research
efforts and focus them on value on uh um
and and so um and so I ended up joining
um um joining events and um it's been
really awesome actually um it's
definitely the uh and when was this this
was in uh
2022 uh so two and a half years ago now
amazing and so tell me what is the state
of accessibility today in in the
digitized world you're obviously looking
at at the space from a bird's eye view
and you have a quite a big quite a lot
of data to look at so how do you what
are you seeing here so um there's
there's so many kind of different ways
to look at that question so I guess um
first of all um one of the things that
it just stands out is how much
accessibility as a need is growing and I
don't mean the number of people who
actually you know um need accessibility
as end users but I mean the number of
companies that have suddenly woken up
and realize that this is something they
have to do something about um mostly for
regulatory reasons uh but not only just
kind of continues to grow and grow so
this is very much a uh you know a a
growing area a growing need for for
technology uh in in in my opinion I
guess um and I say in my opinion because
the other thing that you learn very
quickly about accessibility is that
there are kind of two extremes to trying
to solve the the pro the problem outside
I think of what we're doing one is very
very reliant on um human Auditors human
testers people who will go through your
uh website or your mobile application
and will tell you the problem is and
then you'll turn that into you know a
set of uh uh bugs or product
requirements and things like that and
then someone will go and do that and
then you'll do that again maybe after a
little while in the meantime you're
still releasing features and stuff like
that which have accessibility bugs in
them and you just fix them you know um
um going backwards um on the other hand
there's a couple of um players who claim
to you know one line of JavaScript on
your website and will automatically fix
all of your accessibility issues right
and that's a technology first approach
but unfortunately it's it's also a
fantasy um because the thing about
accessibility is
that in the intention of the product and
the developer is really really important
especially around the more complex areas
of assisted Technologies right so it's
fairly easy to detect and solve color
contrast issues right but if we're
talking about the experience of a screen
reader user or a keyboard user
then in order to know what the assisted
technology is supposed to expose to the
user and how they're supposed to be able
to interact with it you actually have to
understand the in intention of the you
know of the of the design and of the
product right right down to the level of
this UI component serves as a piece of
site navigation or as an menu of actions
they sound really similar but they're
very different from an assist of
Technology uh perspective interesting um
and so where evinced has come kind of
come into the market is that we we're
taking a technology first approach to
accessibility but with a big focus on
helping developers and
designers detect and prevent
accessibility problems um so it's not
about just send it to production and
then either audit it and fix it or some
magic will try and fix it it's actually
about and run
time yeah well in development so we as
they're as they're writing the the
website and as they're writing the
product exactly it's uh you know how do
you make sure that a design comes with
all of the things that it needs so that
a developer can build accessibly how do
you then find all of the accessibility
problems that might exist during
development whether it's while I'm
building a component or while I'm
building a feature or something like
that and that's where all of our
technology is is those are the places
where our technology is geared towards
like everyone we've also seen the growth
of um of geni and so we've also been
opportunistic in those areas so if it
hadn't been for llms I don't think we
would have a AI chatbot in the market
that is geared towards developers to
help answer questions about
accessibility which is kind of a bit of
an offshoot of the work that we're doing
but um um but our main focus is very
much around detection prevention and to
some extent providing remediation but
not automatically runtime but rather to
the developer this is how you might go
about fixing this problem um and so
educating the developers on on kind of
how to solve that I what's been the most
fun experience of being a part of this
journey so far for you um well I'll say
in general what I really love about my
role at evinced is that it's not just
one thing um and so um you know I know
that there are some research managers
who who are really in it for the uh kind
of the I guess what you would call the
data science side of things so models uh
machine learning Ai and that's and that
sort of thing my group kind of does a
bit of everything from writing rule
based algorithms in JavaScript to um
machine learning using computer vision
to for instance identify different types
of elements on a web page to as I
mention this kind of uh you know chatbot
that that that we built so that that
breadth of kind of different ways that
we can bring value and impact the
customer is something that I personally
uh really enjoy it also gives me the
opportunity to to as a group you know
have both short-term and long-term
achievements right so we can do
things you know which are kind of
perhaps lighter on the science side but
provide immate value and then we can
also work on longer term strategic Pro
uh projects which are going to then
change the way that we do things in the
future so those are the kind of on a
high level the most fun things I will
say that
specifically um we built a a new product
uh called the unit tester component
tester it's completely non AI it's pure
kind of uh rule based and it just it all
it took was kind of challenging the
assumptions of our our product what if
we already knew what was the kind of
component someone was trying to build
and what if we had the ability to
interact with the page what we what
could we do so we kind of started with
that that question and then we built a
whole product out of the the you know
based off of those
assumptions um and then the they just um
seeing how you know seeing this new fi
field of things like Rag and uh prompt
engineering and stuff like that
imerge um has also been really fun also
like actually one of the most
challenging things I've I've done but
also most enjoyable was hiring a gen
engineer um like uh which we did half a
year ago and it took about four or five
months um and and just the number of
different profiles of people that kind
of like come from that kind of role and
finding the exact mix of what you're
looking for um was really was really
interesting I got to meet loads of
really interesting people and the person
who we hired to ear is amazing so you
know it's uh it's uh that was very
fulfilling and interesting sounds like
an incredible journey all around you see
thank you so so much for being here and
for sharing these insights with me and
for sharing with me your journey it's
super fascinating and best of luck
continuing with with what you're doing
and whatever else comes in the journey
as well sounds like very important work
so thank you thank you very much thank
you